The answer is that none of these solve our problem.
The third one would be secure, but would be useless,
because there was no way from this to learn the value of M unless you know x,
and there's no way to know x.
The second one doesn't solve our problem, and it's not even possible.
M could be 1.
There is no value of e we could pick that would make m^e when m is 1 exceed n.
So that doesn't work.
The first one is the most plausible, but it also doesn't work.
Let me show you why the first one doesn't work.
Even though the previous attack of just taking the eth root would not work on this.
There's another attack that does, which is just to try all the messages.
We can try for each message, and in this case
the messages were the numbers from 1-365 whatever the set of messages is.
As long as that's small, we can try them all,
and we can try for each of those messages we're going to try encrypting using the public key.
That message--see if it matches the cipher text.
In this case it's not that message that we would try encrypting.
We would try encrypting x + m, since we know the value of x.
We find the one that matches. Then we know what the message was.
Without randomizing the encryption system, this is very dangerous.
If the set of message is small in a public key system,
that's always dangerous because the public key is known.
We can always try encryption in the forward direction and see which one
matches the intercepted cipher text.
If we're going to use RSA in practice, we need a solution to that,
because we can't assume the messages are large and random and from some large set.